farm businesses have enjoyed
exceptionally high prices and incomes of
the last ten years even this year with
somewhat lower crop and livestock prices
farm cash incomes are well above their
long-run average in fact since the early
1980s households that own and operate
farm businesses have consistently
enjoyed higher incomes than the average
American household this is not your
great-grandmother's poverty ribbon
grapes of wrath' farming community
nevertheless Congress continues to
funnel over twenty billion dollars a
year in subsidies to farm businesses
those payments mainly flow to the
largest farm operations whose owners
enjoy incomes and the hundreds of
thousands of dollars many farm subsidy
programs also wastes gas economic
resources for example crop insurance
programs encourage farms to adopt
high-risk strategies and farm fragile
lands several conservation subsidies are
so poorly targeted that they have almost
no impact on the environment so is there
any justification for continuing most
farm subsidy programs the answer quite
simply is no so what do you think about
farm subsidies let us know in your
comments and also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI